california is set to fully reopen june  15th  governor gavin newsom says he's throwing  out the state's color tier system  and other business restrictions the only  catch is if cases go up again  for businesses barely hanging on it is  welcome news however  doctors are uneasy it's good news  because the epidemiology  justifies it by and large but it's a  little surprising because  there are still some counties that are  worse off than others it's a little far  to look forward  like i don't know what's going to be  happening in on june 15th  meanwhile governor newsom faces a  looming recall effort because of his  decisions during the pandemic some  people are critical of them  officials have until april 29 to  determine if there are enough valid  signatures for that recall to move  forward